[Music]
um um
[Music]
a lot of people seem to think that the
galaxy nexus is just another android
phone and that if it's not technically
the best thing out there then they just
shouldn't buy it so to those guys well
i'll be honest while it might be
outclassed just ever so slightly by a
few other handsets out there you guys
have to remember this this is a nexus
this is the only stock android 4.0
device this is the pure google
experience this is the precision of
everything that android is supposed to
be
hey how's it going guys this is marquez
from the mkbhd channel and welcome to
our first look at the samsung galaxy
nexus so if you're ready for this and i
know i am let's go ahead and get started
with this uh go ahead and give this
video a thumbs up and we'll go ahead and
dive right in basically there's no
better place to start on the samsung
galaxy nexus than the display because it
has everything going for it in its favor
first of all it is an oled display and
that means that colors as you can see
really pop and the blacks are pitch
black and you can hardly tell them apart
from the bezel so it's really cool that
it's a 4.65 inch display and to top that
all off it doesn't hurt that it's a 1280
1280x720
hd display so watching videos and
content on this display looks absolutely
ridiculously good i'm gonna go ahead and
say it uh this is the best mobile
display i've ever used this is hands
down the best mobile phone display and
it's easy to tell here that the phone is
responsive as hell with that 1.2
gigahertz dual core processor and a gig
of ram
but
you know what's it like to use the phone
what is it like to own a verizon samsung
galaxy nexus
[Applause]
[Music]
the galaxy nexus is fast and i'm not
just saying that because i came from a
two-year-old og droid or because i want
you guys to believe it's fast it's
actually really fast opening and closing
apps animations the hardware
acceleration it's all noticeably faster
than i'm used to and i have tested other
phones before now something else equally
awesome but also sometimes under
appreciated about this phone is the
android 4.0 keyboard while you can get
that on other phones because it's free
in the android market uh having that
4.65 in the screen makes a really really
fast type and i guarantee you in my full
galaxy nexus review i'll show you speech
to text which is absolutely phenomenal
and worked nearly flawlessly every time
but another neat way to show off the
screen clarity of the galaxy nexus is by
turning it sideways while watching a
youtube video first time i turned a
landscape while watching youtube my jaw
dropped and i was in tears it was it was
unbelievable
watching 720p videos you might even want
to watch this video in 720p on your
phone see how good it looks it looks
amazing on the galaxy nexus
[Music]
if you've heard of the samsung galaxy
nexus you've probably heard of this face
unlock which is facial recognition to
unlock your phone it's in the security
settings registers your face and then
you can unlock it with your face at any
time i found that while it's nice that
it works i probably won't be using this
as the swipe gesture to unlock the
screen is just much more fast
now there's something about this phone
that's gotten mixed reactions and that's
the camera now there's something
awesomely awesome and something pitiful
about this phone's camera as you can see
instant shutter is awesome and the
software everything about the software
is great taking panorama photos is
awesome
but something that's kind of pitiful is
the sensor it's only a five megapixel
sensor and while i do appreciate that it
takes decent photos at instant speed the
camera photos don't look that great the
video was much more impressive and
that'll be covered in the full review
but other than that you know there are a
lot of beautiful subtle things that are
just nice about this phone like the
notification light here and the
placement of the headphone jack and i
know i didn't really cover everything
today and i didn't really cover
everything realistic like battery life
and
i don't know calling people on this
phone but trust me it does that very
well uh but seriously i'll cover a lot
of these things in my full review in a
full a couple weeks when i really get to
know everything about this phone either
way thanks for liking this video and
thanks for watching it and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace